[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg guten Abend schön dass Sie
dabei sind wie auch Sven Foss für den
Sport schönen guten Abend und das sind
die Nachrichtenthemen von
heute Hoffnung in mitten von Terror 2000
Ausländer konnten Gaza in einer Woche
verlassen im abgeriegelten
Küstenstreifen sind weiter VI Menschen
auf der
Flucht wichtiges Signal für Kiev die
EU-Kommission empfiehlt
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Ukraine
fordert aber auch weitere
Reformen und wieder auf Kurs der BVB
schüttelt den Bundesliga Frust ab und
feiert einen Heimerfolg in der Champions
League zweites Spiel gegen Newcastle
zweiter
Sieg wir beginnen mit der Situation im
Gazastreifen nach israelischen Angaben
flohen dort allein heute etwa 50.000
Menschen vom heftig umkämpften Norden in
den Süden in einem fluchtkorridor den
die israelische Armee zwischen 10 und 15
Uhr freigegeben hatte die
Terrororganisation Hamas spricht
mittlerweile von mehr als
10500 Toten in dem abgeriegelten
Küstenstreifen überprüfen lassen sich
diese Zahlen nicht Henriette deier
berichtet auch heute rückt die
israelische Armee nach eigenen Angaben
immer weiter in Gaza vor Bilder die
zeigen sollen unter dem Gelände eines
Vergnügungsparks am Rande der Stadt
entdeckt die israelische Armee ein
Tunnelsystem der
Hamas wir werden gewinnen wir werden
nicht aufhören bis wir gewonnen haben
ich bin im ständigen Kontakt mit
US-Präsident Biden dessen Beistand wir
anerkennen den Beistand des
amerikanischen darin schwingt ein aber
mit iden fordert eine dreitägige
Kampfpause um vielleicht einige der
Geiseln zu befreien dies lehnt Netanyahu
bisher immer ab nur kurze Feuerpausen
damit sich die Menschen vom Norden in
den Süden bewegen können Zustimmung
dafür auch von Israels Oppositionsführer
Lapid was die Hamas will ist Greueltaten
beginnen und dann sagen lass uns einen
Waffenstillstand schließen aber wir
werden keinen Waffenstillstand Schließen
der der Hamas dient aber wir werden
unser Bestes tun um das Leiden der
Menschen in Gaza zu
verhindern währenddessen versuchen
Menschen weiter dem Gasastreifen zu
entfliehen Richtung Ägypten wie Nala
Galas die deutsche kommt jeden Tag ich
hoffe heute dass ich noch mal
durchkommen ich hoffe ich bin sehr sehr
krank ich kann weiter nichtr weiter
hierben menschliches Leid und
militärische Erfolge die israelische
Armee nach eigenen Angaben seit Beginn
des Gazakrieges 130 Tunnel der
islamistischen Hamas
zerstört unsere Reporterin Katrin
Eigendorf ist in sterot im Grenzgebiet
zum Gazastreifen Katrin welche Strategie
verfolgt die Hamas warum nimmt sie so
viele palästinensische Opfer in
kauf ja die Strategie der Hamas ist der
israelischen Regierung eigentlich von
Anfang an Klage Wesen und wir haben
jetzt lernt in einem Interview was die
Hamas Führung der New York Times gegeben
hat dass sie damit auch richtig liegt
das Ziel ist nicht sagt die Hamas
Führung gegenüber der New York Times den
Gazastreifen zu regieren oder dort in
irgendeiner Form ja ein ein Land
aufzubauen sondern das Ziel sei Israel
in einen Krieg zu verwickeln das ist ja
das was im Prinzip hier seit dem 7
Oktober passiert und das bedeutet
natürlich dass für die Bevölkerung für
die Zivilbevölkerung Gazas das eine
außerordentlich schlimme Lage ist denn
wir haben ja immer wieder erlebt dass
die Hamas sie als zivile Schutzschilder
benutzt dass es die Hamas für die Hamas
nicht eine große Rolle spielt wie viel
Zivilisten hier sterben oder verletzt
werden und das hat sich eigentlich in
diesem Interview mit der New York Times
noch einmal ganz klar bestätigt und da
hat die hamasführung auch keinen Hel
draus gemacht dass sie das in Kauf nimmt
dass hier viele Zivilisten viele
palästinensische Zivilisten in Gaza auch
weiter ums Leben kommen und verletzt
werden danke schön für diese
Einschätzung aus der rot Katrin
Eigendorf war das über aktuelle
Entwicklungen informieren wir Sie jetzt
auch auf WhatsApp einfach unseren ZDF
heute Kanal abonnieren wie das finden
Sie in der Anleitung auf unserer
Homepage ZDF heute und in unserer App wo
stehen die G7 Staaten mit Blick auf den
Gaza Krieg zuletetzt waren sich die
großen westlichen Industrienationen
dabei nicht einig jetzt beim Treffen
ihrer außen Minister in Toko waren sie
bemüht mit einer Stimme zu sprechen zur
G7 gehören neben Deutschland auch Kanada
die USA Frankreich Großbritannien
Italien und Japan was die Gruppe im
Interesse Israels und der Palästinenser
gemeinsam fordert dazu Andreas
Künast es gibt diesmal so viel
auszutauschen und vielleicht auch
auszuräumen dass die zuletzt öffentlich
uneinigen Europäerinnen flitz mü damit
Deutschland und Frankreich nicht fehlen
auf dem G7 Foto von tok es hat für
Aufsehen und für Enttäuschung gesorgt
dass die westlichen Industrienationen im
Nahostkonflikt nicht mehr mit einer
Stimme sprechen in der UNO bei der
arabischen Resolution hatten die USA mit
Nein gestimmt Frankreich mit ja
Großbritannien und die anderen auch
Deutschland mit Enthaltung in Japan
haben die G7 ihre Positionen insofern
vereint Terror der Hamas Israel nicht
von der Verantwortung entbindet alles in
seiner Macht stehende zu tun um zivile
Opfer zu vermeiden und die humanitäre
Krise in Gaza zu lindern usaußenminister
blinken hat gerade in Israel für eine
längere Feuerpause geworben im G7
Abschlussdokument ist von humanitären
Feuerpausen die Rede vor der Presse geht
blinken noch weiter um Frieden zu
erreichen dürfe es keine ibung der
Palästinenser
geben keine Wiederbesetzung des
Gazastreifens kein Versuch ihn zu
blockieren oder zu belagern keine
Verkleinerung des Gebiets von Gaza
keinen Zweifel lassen die G7 am recht
Israels sich zu verteidigen der
politische Westen stellt sich klar an
die Seite Israels gleichzeitig
kritisieren die G7 indirekt aber
deutlich die Wortwahl und zum Teil das
Vorgehen der Regierung
netanu zuor hatte Reise von mehr als 200
deutschen aus dem Gazastreifen bestätigt
das gebe Hoffnung inmitten einer
furchtbaren
Lage lassen Sie sich nicht von der Hamas
instrumentalisieren dazu hat
Bundespräsident Steinmeier in
Deutschland lebende Menschen mit
palästinensischen und arabischen Wurzeln
aufgerufen bei einem runden Tisch im
Schloss belvue sagte Steinmeer er
erwarte dass man sich gemeinsam gegen
Terrorismus Wende gegen Volksverhetzung
und gegen den Aufruf zur Vernichtung
Israels eingeladen waren Menschen die
für ein Zusammenleben ohne
Antisemitismus und ohne
muslimfeindlichkeit
stehen die Wirtschaftsaussichten sind
mau das sagt jetzt auch der
Sachverständigenrat der Bundesregierung
für dieses Jahr rechnen die sogenannten
Wirtschaftsweisen mit einem Minus von
0,4% fürs nächste Jahr mit einem
Wachstum von
0,7% ihre Liste mit verbess
besserungsvorschlägen ist lang unter
anderem drängen die Wissenschaftler
darauf dass die Deutschen später in
Rente gehen Christian Volk
berichtet Druck frisch und mehr als 400
seitenick das Jahresgutachten der
Wirtschaftsweisen vor allem strukturelle
Probleme machen den Ökonomen große
sorgen für die nächsten 15 Jahre durch
den Renteneintritt der Babyboomer
verschlechtert sich bei uns die Relation
zwischen denjenigen die z.B das
gesetzliche Rentensystem finanzieren und
denjenigen die dort Leistungen erwarten
sehr stark die Politik hat das Thema in
den letzten Jahren so ein bisschen
schleifen lassen deshalb drängen die
Ökonomen auf eine Reform der
Rentenversicherung und ein höheres
Renteneintrittsalter bereits jetzt seien
die mittelfristigen Wachstumsaussichten
auf einem historischen Tiefstand die
Wirtschaftsweisen fordern mehr
Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland mehr
Investitionen in Maschinen aber auch
Roboter und IT und weniger Bürokratie
der Kanzler zeigt sich
zuversichtlich wenn in Deutschland
investiert werden soll dann kann das
nicht so sein dass jeder denkt das ist
jetzt eine lange Strecke bis ich meine
Genehmigung habe und loslegen kann
deshalb wollen wir mehr Tempo nach
Deutschland bringen Innovationen und
Wachstum das sollen auch junge
Unternehmen anstoßen bei deren
Finanzierung gibt es laut den
Wirtschaftsweisen aber einen erheblichen
Nachholbedarf und nicht nur dort sagt
die
CDU wir brauchen bessere
Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten andere
Steuersätze wir brauchen flexiblere
Arbeitszeiten Energie Preise runter das
ist sehr klar und vor allen Dingen muss
dereguliert werden die Bürger aber auch
die Betriebe die können nicht mehr die
sind am Rande gerade das Positive am
eher düsteren Jahresgutachten im
kommenden Jahr wird die Wirtschaft wohl
wieder leicht wachsen und die Inflation
laut Prognose auf
2,6%
sinken eine Zahl sticht im Jahresbericht
der Bundespolizei heraus 92000 s
unerlaubte einreisen das sind 60% mehr
als
2021 die illegale Migration erreicht
damit einen neuen Höchstwert und in
Ministerin fäser geht von
weitersteigenden Zahlen aus ein
Schwerpunkt war die bandenmäßig
organisierte schleuserkriminalität Klaus
brotbeck das stellt die Bundespolizei
immer häufiger fest großschleusungen ein
neuer Trend Gruppen um 20 Personen die
in Fahrzeugen oder zu Fuß versuchen die
deutsche Grenze zu überschreiten
flexible und überraschende Maßnahmen
statt stationäre Grenzkontrollen führten
zu mehr
aufgriffen was wir nicht machen ist die
Grenze schließen an keiner Stelle und
wir beeinträchtigen an keiner Stelle die
Freizügigkeit und an keiner Stelle
beeinträchtigen wir den freien
Warenverkehr das tun wir nicht die
Grenze schließen tut Nordkorea wir tun
das nicht
280.000 Verstöße gegen das
aufenthaltsges z stellte die
Bundespolizei fest 64% mehr als im Jahr
davor 18 000 Abschiebungen führte sie
durch 2700 schleußer wurden festgenommen
die gehen immer rabiater vor gefährden
Menschenleben wie hier Mitte Oktober
beim Versuch der Polizei zu entkommen
immer häufiger wird auch die
Bundespolizei selbst zum Ziel von Gewalt
2602 Angriffe in
2022 709 Beamte wurden verletzt zwei pro
Tag derer Polizistinnen und Polizisten
angreift und damit diejenigen die jeden
Tag für uns auf der Straße ihren Kopf
hinhalten und für Sicherheit sorgen das
allerschlimmste und deswegen müssen
diese Täter auch mit allerhte des
Rechtsstaates rechnen einfacher wird es
nicht praktisch alle Zahlen steigen
höher und
schneller die Republik Moldau und die
Ukraine sind auf ihrem Weg in die EU
einen wichtigen Schritt weiter die
EU-Kommission empfiehlt
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit beiden
Ländern aufzunehmen
kommissionspräsidentin von derlein
sprach von einem historischen Tag mahnte
die Ukraine aber auch die angestoßenen
Reformen
fortzusetzen vor allem in drei Bereichen
muss das Land noch nachbessern bei der
Bekämpfung von Korruption beim
Minderheitenschutz und bei der
Überwindung von zu viel Einfluss von
Oligarchen die EU-Kommission empfiehlt
ihren Mitgliedern also
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Ukraine
Ulf Roller in Brüssel wie ist es
einzuordnen also ich glaube das ist die
gute Botschaft auf Brüssel auf die die
Ukraine wirklich dringend gewartet hat
das Land ist in einer ganz ganz Schwien
Situation es befindet sich in einem
abnutzungskrieg mit Russland mit hohen
Verletzten und deshalb und vielen Toten
eben auch und deshalb braucht es
unbedingt dieses Signal dass es eine
Perspektive hat in die EU zu kommen
diese Perspektive wurde von
kommissionspräsidentin noch quasi giert
mit einem großen Lob 90% der
reformauflagen habe die Ukraine bereits
erfüllt 10 % fehlen noch gerade beim
Thema Justizreform und Korruption und
deshalb will man im März noch mal
nachschauen wie weit die Ukraine
gekommen ist bereits im Dezember jetzt
findet der Gipfel der Regierungschefs
statt und die werden dann endgültig
entscheiden ob die beitrittsverhandlung
aufgenommen werden aber wie gesagt bei
90% glaube ich kann man davon ausgehen
dass das passiert danke schön Brüssel
Ulf
Röller auch wenn eine EU-Mitgliedschaft
der Ukraine immer noch in weiter Ferne
liegt für die Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
dürfte das Signal aus Brüssel ein
Hoffnungsschimmer sein Dara Hassan ZAD
berichtet Soldaten an der Südfront seit
623 Tagen im Krieg die ukrainische
Großoffensive stockt auch weil Waffen
fehlen die Europa nicht liefert
zeitgleich treibt die Ukraine
tiefgreifende Form voran um EU Kriterien
für Beitrittsgespräche zu
erfüllen ich erinnere mich wie wir die
Bewerbung zum Kandidatenstatus
ausgefüllt haben überall
Bombenangriffe wir saßen in den Bunkern
und haben diese Dokumente verfasst alles
vorbereitet selbstbewusst zählt Olena
die Fortschritte auf beim Kampf gegen
Korruption bei Reform der
verfassungsjustiz doch es fehlen Gesetze
zum Schutz von Minderheiten gegen
lobbiismus es ist auch eine Frage der
abwegung wie man die Reformen bewertet
bodomir demonstrierte auf dem Maidan wo
der Weg nach Europa 2014 begann heute
dient er in der
Armee damals wurdest du verfolgt wenn du
dich nicht auf die Diebe eingelassen
hast heute werden die Schurken
verfolgt wenn man sich das vor Augen
führt welchen Weg die Ukraine
zurückgelegt hat welches Momentum
entstanden
es ist wirklich
unglaublich volodimir ist stolz auf das
Erreichte es sind Menschen wie er die
täglich die Kraft aufbringen die Ukraine
von innen zu reformieren und
andererseits an der Front den russischen
Angriffskrieg
abwehren zurück nach Deutschland dass
man vor einer geschlossenen Apotheke
steht das kann in diesem Monat öfter
vorkommen denn die Apotheker haben
bundesweit Proteste angekündigt heute
etwa in Norddeutschland in Hannover
kamen einige hundert zu einer zentralen
Kundgebung sie fordern eine höhere
Vergütung pro verkauftem Medikament
außerdem wehren sie sich gegen Pläne von
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach er will
in bestimmten Fällen in schlecht
versorgten Gebieten die gesetzlichen
Anforderungen an Apotheken
senken mit einer Spezialeinheit musste
die Polizei am Vormittag in einer
Hamburger Schule anrücken vor den Augen
anderer Schüler sollen zwei Jugendliche
dort eine Lehrerin mit einer Schusswaffe
bedroht haben anschließend seien die
beiden aus dem Raum einer achten Klasse
geflohen so die Polizei sie sollen
zwischen 12 und 15 Jahre alt sein
vorsichtshalber sperrten die Beamten des
Gelände ab die Schüler wurden in
Sicherheit gebracht inzwischen hat die
Polizei zwei Spielzeugpistolen
sichergestellt dieses Jahr wird
europäischen Wissenschaftlern zu folgen
wohl das wärmste werden seit Beginn der
Wetter aufzeich
nach dem temperaturrekord im Oktober sei
das ziemlich sicher sagen die
Wissenschaftler des EU
klimawandeldienstes Kopernikus
Ursache sei neben dem Menschen gemachten
Klimawandel auch das Wetterphänomen el
ninho mit steigender Temperatur wachse
in Zukunft auch das Risiko für
Extremwetterereignisse wie
hitzewähen und jetzt Fußball sen der
Start in die Champions League Woche
hätte aus deutscher Sicht nicht besser
laufen soll das hätte ich nicht schöner
formulieren können vor allem RB Leipzig
hatte Grund zum Jubel mit dem 2 Z ein
Sieg im Dauerregen von Belgrad haben es
die Sachsen vorzeitig ins Achtelfinale
geschat schafft zauberfuß chavi Simons
machte mal wieder den
Unterschied schon in der 8 Minute spielt
sich Xavi Simons im Strafraum
selbstbewusst durch die Belgrader Abwehr
und liefert ein Traumtor zum
1:0 RB dominiert von Beginn an doch erst
in der 77 Minute trifft Lis opender zum
Leipzig hätte da auch mit Toren führen
können und dann wird es plötzlich noch
mal richtig eng für Leipzig die zu viel
zulassen ein Eigentor in der 81 Minute
von hendri bringt RB dann richtig in die
bridulie aber Keeper blaswig rettet das
Team von Trainer Marco Rose somit steht
Leipzig schon nach vier Spielen der
Gruppenphase als Zweiter hinter
Manchester City sicher im Achtelfinale
der Champions
League alle Spiele alle Tore von 23 Uhr
an in unser high Sendung unter anderem
mit dem Heimspiel der Bayern gegen
galatasarai Istanbul und Union Berlin in
Neapel außerdem geht's um Borussia
Dortmund der BVB verbesserte gestern
seine Chancen aufs Achtelfinale beim 2:0
Sieg gegen Newcastle erzielte
Nationalstürmer Niklas Füllkrug seinen
ersten Treffer in der Königsklasse der
BVB ist nun sogar Gruppen
erster die Champions League wirkt Wunder
nach der bundesligaleite gegen die
Bayern überzeugt der BVB gegen Newcastle
das 1:0 in der 26 Minute bereiten Niklas
vüllkrugck und Marcel sabizzer gemeinsam
vor füllkrugck macht dann sein erstes
Tor in der Champions
League Julian Brand hat viele gute
Szenen die in der 79 Minute führt zum
2:0
entstand und das war heute ein wichtiges
Spiel in ein ganz ganz wichtigen
Wettbewerb wo glaube ich wenig Leute
dran glauben oder von Anfang an dran
geglaubt haben dass wir diese Gruppe
überstehen als Tabellenführer der
Champions League Gruppe F fährt Dortmund
nun zu zum nächsten Spiel nach Mailand
in 3
Wochen und das war's vom Sport aber und
jetzt fehlt noch das Wetter Lotto ach so
die Gewinnzahlen lauten 1 12 18 34 39 48
und die Superzahl 8 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf
lotto.zf.de und im ZF Text auf Seite
557 und jetzt das Wetter morgen wird's
nass die Details hat gleich östtin terli
um
R begrüßt Sie Marietta Slomka im
heutejournal wir wünschen noch einen
schönen Abend und bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schön guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter nach
einem relativ trockenen trag kommt jetzt
neuer Regen auf und das sehen wir hier
mit diesem Frontensystem kommt der Regen
ins Land und zieht in Bändern im
Tagesverlauf ostwärts bereits in der
Nacht regnet es im Nordwesten
Deutschlands und nach Norden hin ganz im
Südosten hier Richtung Bayern trocken
und an den Alpen wird es am kältesten
mit Temperaturen bis
-3° generell ist es hier nach Südosten
in kälter als sonst im Land am mildesten
am niederrein mit + 10°
morgen also nass mit weiterem Regen der
im Tagesverlauf nach Osten zieht
zeitweise ist der Wind auch mal recht
frisch aus südwestlichen Richtungen ja
und sonnig bleibt es im Südosten hier
wenige Wolken bei höchsten Temperaturen
bis 13° im Osten Deutschlands sonst
liegen wir bei 7 bis 12° die nächsten
Tage werden wieder wechselhafter es
kommt weiterer Regen auf 6 bis 11° am
Freitag Samstag mischen sich obal von
800 m auch Schnee locken dazu und
Gewitter gibt's auch Sonntag ist es
kühler bei 4 bis 9° schönen Abend